[Music]
with college graduation season here
we're taking a closer look at the job
market for the class of 2023. nearly 75
percent of new grads are worried that
the current economy will affect their
job prospects according to monster.com
as Nancy Chen shows us they face hiring
freezes and layoffs in some Industries
and may be wondering what's next
[Music]
for the class of 2023 it's hard not to
get caught up in the excitement and
thrill of graduation day it's very much
I don't think it's hit me yet that I
graduated I'd ask these grads what's
next and you'll likely hear a range of
responses what's next for you guys
taking a nice long vacation and then
starting work at a bank I'm looking for
jobs right now I know it's like peak
season for graduates I am doing civil
engineering there's a lot of demand the
job market is really hard right now
that's because this year's class is
entering a bumpy labor market after
starting College in Fall 2019 just
months before the pandemic hit according
to LinkedIn hiring overall is down 29
since April 2022 while hiring for
entry-level jobs requiring a college
degree has dropped nearly 32 percent CBS
News business analyst Joe sessinger why
is it so tough right now well the labor
market is really in transition we had
explosive job growth for sort of the
first half half of the pandemic era and
things started to turn and when the
Federal Reserve started raising interest
rates and growth started to slow down we
saw job growth start to decelerate which
means even more challenges to navigate
especially with recent layoffs in the
tech and finance Industries and the rise
in AI technology if there's one class
that is such an interesting case study
it is this class of 2023 more than any
other class Scott dubrovsky is indeed's
career Trends expert what we are seeing
in how they search for jobs and find
jobs it is working to the advantage of
the class of 2023. they are trained in
uncertainty and finding the right path
that works for them because they had to
do it over the past four years are there
still opportunities for graduates right
now what this year's class is stumbling
upon is that the industries that many of
them thought they would be going into
that is not the case so for instance
many people who thought they'd be going
into Tech which has been been riddled
with layoffs are actually finding
opportunities in retail travel and
tourism along with being versatile
dubrowsky also recommends focusing on
building skills and experience rather
than getting a certain job title right
off the bat as well as remembering to
negotiate even in an uncertain Market
because it could impact pay for years to
come
also this graduation season there will
be plenty of Pop as usual even if the
circumstances are changing once again
overall are you optimistic I am I'm
optimistic I think I hope
she hopes now despite that uncertain
labor market these graduates are still
pretty optimistic according to
monster.com 88 percent of graduates who
are job hunting are confident they will
get an offer shortly after graduation
which is an even higher percentage than
last year well they're confident I hope
you're right I love the confidence even
though they're looking at numbers that
are pretty Stark down 32 percent for
jobs requiring a college degree level
yeah
if I were a high school grad right now
I'd be saying look carpentry Plumbing
electricity you'll never be unemployed
the soccer generation what do we know uh
Nancy thank you very much